okay so haunting movies they're actually
not innately [ __ ] it's just a lot of
directors out there are lazy so director
James Wan has come back to town to show
us all how it's done
so hey directors out there pay attention
the conjuring 2 so the conjuring 2 is
directed by James Wan we follow our
favorite paranormal investigating couple
the warrants or pretty much straight up
Ghost Busters at this point that's what
they do and this time they go across the
pong to England where there is a family
being terrorized by this entity in
particular this entity is latching on to
and terrorizing this little girl so the
Warrens come into town to try to make it
right this movie was effective man I'm
talking like don't look in the rearview
mirror of your car when you're driving
home at night effective cuz you know
it's there and it's gonna be looking
right back at you seriously after that
Annabelle abomination I was like maybe
we should just let the story of this
whole universe it's kind of lay down
rest die but now man James Wan
effectively directs this movie and gives
us not only a great haunting movie not
only a great creepy movie not only a
great scary movie but a great sequel in
that genre what's the first hour or so
in this movie I'm build-up aside was
just non-stop anxiety it was one creepy
scene building the tension having the
anxiety amp up and then when that scenes
done it's another scene creepy scene
anxiety building that scene was done you
went to another scene you're like oh my
god it's just not stopping which tells
me that the movie knows what it is man
the movies here to scare us so hey yeah
let's have some scare fest I'm not
talking jump scare fest there are a
couple of jump scares in here but they
were more scare than jump even the jump
scares in this movie goes to the scene
that the jump scares gonna take place in
and you see the ghosty face in front of
you and it gives your brain a second to
register you're like oh that's and
that's when it jumps when your brain has
time to process what's going to scare
you before it actually scares you that's
what makes it organics what makes it
real then the next hour in this movie
was the investigative part of its when
the Warrens come in and really there's
that question of is this a hoax or is it
not kids are liars man what can we say
that just master manipulators so I like
the fact this movie kind of tugs at your
mind like that like wait a minute is it
this way or that way
hmmm the camera angles the shots the
implication the 10
it James Wong uses it so well even in
the scenes where you're like us familiar
I've seen this situation before
but it's filmed in a ways like now it
feels new here's that same situation
done the way you should probably see it
a movie like this makes the tension that
much more makes the peril feel more real
you see in a haunting movie like this
what the ghost or spirit is doing is
every bit as important as how they're
doing it and how they're doing it is
illustrated by the director with the
camera shots the camera angle so
lighting the audio all of it comes
together and if it comes together well
by a director who can do it well you
might just have yourself an effective
haunting movie if not well do you join
the rabble of shitty haunting movies
don't worry you have a lot of company
there because there are a lot of them
best thing I can say if you're gonna
have gripes about this movie it's that
in the end it is a haunting movie with
situational circumstance that you've
seen before in which case you can always
argue that everything you see in a movie
has been done before it just hasn't been
shown like that like yeah I've seen this
sword fight in a movie a hundred times
everyone before 1977 did but did they
see it like that not until that and big
props to the little girl in this movie
she carried a lot of this movie and she
had to work if she didn't work if she
sucked it acting this movie would fall
luckily she did a really good job in
this movie there's a bright future ahead
for this girl I'm telling it guys in the
end the conjuring 2 impressed me I
really enjoyed the conjuring one but the
conjuring 2 was something more because I
had heard yeah the conjuring wasn't so
great so I saw it and I was like oh yeah
that is good but for a haunting scary
horror movie sequel I'm like those never
work out and I watched this movie I'm
like oh my god I want to say more are we
making a trilogy let's do it I'm on
board and in the end when it comes to
hauntings I'm a bit of a skeptic I
haven't seen anything in my life that
would make me say yeah that's real stuff
so for me to get out of a movie like
this and then go home and see that the
bedroom door is open in the lightest oov
and I just want to close that door so I
don't have to look into the dark room
it's pretty effective good job and I
will say the conjuring 2 is certainly
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray
better than sinister - I love sinister
one sinister - mm-hmm all right guys
with the conjuring - have you seen it
what did you think about it or have you
had a haunting situational circumstance
in your life any paranormal experiences
whatever
is whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more